lots of people that show up to Navy SEAL
training have the same story that I did
didn't really do anything out of high
school U screwed up College got kicked
out didn't have a job no one in my
family has a history of being in the
military just seemed cool decided I'd go
try out there's loads of people that go
to Seal training that are like super
accomplished people but they wash out
really really quickly the folks that
come in that are like I've done nothing
with my life and this is what I want to
do I'm going to reinvent myself they got
nothing to lose because they've never
done anything but if you're the
professional swimmer The Professional
football player people expect you to
become an Navy SEAL and as soon as it
gets hard the instructors remind them
that doesn't matter what you did before
it only matters what you're doing now
the people that have been massively
successful before becoming seals they're
not used to failing just about anybody
can go try out and it's whoever is at
the end is a Navy SEAL and and I love
the idea of whoever you were before you
became a seal gets replaced with the
person who becomes a seal